[Musique]
depuis quelques jours et les révélations
d'un livre accusant le politologue
olivier duhamel d'inceste un nouveau
mouvement est né sur internet avec le
hashtag mitu inceste avec ce mot clé des
milliers d'internautes témoignent des
violences sexuelles qu'ils ont subis de
la part de membres de leurs familles et
témoignage terrifiant et poignant qui
dans certains cas réveil des dossiers
vieux de dizaines d'années c'est par
exemple le cas de jonathan de l'oeil
l'une des victimes du très médiatique
procès d'outreau
à l'époque il dénoncé par an qui ont
abusé sexuellement de lui lorsqu'il
avait 6 ans et immobiliers de ce
processeur dit il s'est révélé être un
véritable fiasco
un procès en plusieurs volets qui a
débuté en 2004 et s'est achevé plus de
dix ans après par l'acquittement d'une
grande partie des accusés douze enfants
sont reconnus par la justice comme
victimes de viols d'agressions sexuelles
de corruption de mineurs et de
proxénétisme
cinq ans après la fin de ce procès ce
hashtag libère la parole pour ceux qui
n'ont pas pu s'exprimer ou qui n'ont pas
encore tout dit et offre une tribune
inédite à des millions de victimes
ce soir jonathan de l'oeil est avec nous
en direct pour nous parler de son
histoire des 102 milles les enfants de
myriam badaoui et thierry dol et
commence à accuser leurs parents d'abus
sexuels et se confient à leurs familles
d'accueil et nous sommes avec jonathan
de l'est merci jonathan merci merci
d'être là et merci d'avoir choisi touche
pas à mon poste pour venir nous parler
tout ça pour tous venir nous parler de
ce drame vous êtes donc un des enfants
de myriam badaoui thierry de les
condamner pour avoir maltraitées et
violées leurs enfants vous et vos frères
vos parents qu'est ce qui représente
pour vous aujourd'hui
rien rien n'existe plus n'existe pas pas
pour vos deux frères aussi comment pour
vos deux frères séparés trois frères son
frère mais bon pour votre frère aussi
c'est ces fermetures durée de grâce est
fini
fermeture du rythme est ce que vous vous
rappelez du cauchemar qu'a commencé
alors que vous aviez 8,9 me rappelais
pas mais ces voix là il paraît que ça a
commencé quand vous aviez 8 nov - c'est
ça c'est des attestations de l'expert
qui ont été faites pendant l'instruction
qui ont attesté quand vu des lésions que
j'avais ça se référer à quelques mois
alors sont d'abord des violences de la
maltraitance des coûts ceux ci avaient
été hospitalisés plus d'une dizaine de
fois dès la première année de votre vie
c'est ça se sait
j'avais vécu avec vos parents et vos
trois frères jusqu'à vos six ans c'est
ça et ses six ans de maltraitances des
abus sexuels mais six ans de calvaire
c'est ça commence a commencé ces abus
sexuels
c'est un jeu que mon père a lancé alors
d'une visite d'un couple de voisins ce
que vous pouvez parler bien fort
jonathan je sais pas si je me sens très
ému je suis désolé je finalise les vingt
ans il on est on est bien
c'est un serial c'est un jeu qu'on t'a a
lancé pendant le
visite du couple de voisins c'est un
il voulait lancer un jeu sexuel entre 4
et cependant la commande coco couple
c'est ça donc nous on était à côté dans
le salon et on a commencé à entendre du
bruit on est rentré dans le salon voilà
et là vous avez vu est en fait donc un
de mes frères qui a dit mais qu'est ce
que qu'est ce que vous faites et mon
père s'est levé a dit ben tu vas savoir
donc là ça commence comme ça c'est ça a
commencé comme ça et après c'est ça
l'engrenage
donc comment ça c'est magnifique us
commencent à se manifester sans gants
cet engrenage
il ya des choses judiciairement parlant
syrie dit que vous pouvez vraiment
enchanté voilà preniez de risque des
choses que je ne peux pas dire mais
c'est compliqué c'est parce que il ya
certaines choses que je peux pas dire
mais que je conte que vous pourrez avoir
l'occasion de le lire dans ce livre
parce que j'ai j'ai l'autorisation de le
faire bien sûr mais c'est un leurre marc
vous dites que des tout-petits votre
père vous menacez pour que vous ne
parliez pas c'est ce qui se passait à la
maison c'est un as et même de mort oui
oui vous disais quoi
enfin il jouait sur la pression
psychologique on ne pourrait plus
rentrer à la maison que l'on pourrait pu
revoir papa et maman est dans la tête
d'un enfant 4 5 ans le fait est de
pouvoir papa et maman quand on n'a pas
conscience de ce qui nous arrive c'est
très compliqué parce que vous vivez des
choses incroyables même avec des dédits
sévices incroyable oui oui vous raconter
dans le livre c'est ça avec des
fourchettes notamment oui qu'est-ce qui
si vous tout y passait en fait tout
était tout est organisé je sais pas
comment ils expliquaient et votre mère
et votre père a été et est sur la même
longueur d'onde le tue sa probable il ya
votre mère elle lui disait pas parfois
je l'air défendre et je la défendrai pas
à ce qu'on a toujours l'occasion de
partir à un moment donné elle n'était
pas attaché à un radiateur rien du tout
enfin on se doit on est en capacité de
défendre ses enfants et quoi qu'il
arrive donc oui forcément c'était
vraiment le couple barbares n'a pas de
limites
abject alors en 2000 à 6 ans au maire
demande aux services sociaux que ses
enfants
donc soit pas là c'est en famille
d'accueil c'est çà et là c'est un mythe
heureux de comment partir vous êtes
limite euros de partir de cet enfer pas
tant que ça pas tant que ça pas tant que
ça parce qu'il faut remettre les choses
dans le bon contexte quand on a
cinq ans et demi être capable de faire
la différence entre ce qui est bien et
ce qui est mal c'est très compliqué faut
vraiment se mettre ça dans la tête et on
comprenait pas en fait c'est un tout à
rien et on ne comprend rien est ce qui
se passe c'est une après-midi banal mon
père demande à mes frères d'aller lui
chercher de la bière ma mère à ce moment
là s'ils s'y refuse et dessin avec lui
pour l'empêcher de remonter et là une
valse endiablée d'affaires par la
fenêtre en furie je suis resté j'étais
j'ai encore cette image en tête j'étais
dans le canapé avec ma game boy dans les
mains il me l'a arraché des mains il a
plié en deux comme ça et lâcheté par la
fenêtre et ensuite il m'a il m'a passé
au dessus du ce coup
du cinquième étage
menaçant de me jeter si c'est ma mère ne
remontait pas vous avez quel âge
aujourd'hui jonathan 26 26 ans c'est
l'effet qui remonte à 20 ans très
longtemps mais quelle est votre relation
avec vos autres frères après c'est très
compliqué très compliqué ouais mais ça
vous a pas soudé tout ça c'est pas plus
facile à dire qu'à faire
c'est le contexte c'est la façon comment
on a vécu on a des nouvelles on se prend
des nouvelles ne sait pas on n'a pas
vraiment de relation plus intime que ça
deux frangins le fait qu'aujourd'hui
jonathan dans la vie je travaille dans
une boîte de sécurité informatique
d'accord voilà je suis très content au
collègue
il savait tout ce qui vous était arrivé
où ils vont la prendre avec le livre la
prendre la non 20 j'en parle d'un an
j'en parle quand je me sens libre d'en
parler ça fait du bien ça fait du bien
d'en parler par importe le jugement
au bout d'un moment il faut il faut être
capable d'en parler pour libérer cette
parole parce que c'est un poids qui est
lourd qui est très lourd même 20 ans
après et on se retrouve au but il faut
vraiment avoir conscience de ce que ben
d'où le titre de ce que peut représenter
une vide en fin de la sphère du trot
c'est c'est ça aujourd'hui vous vous
sentez que vous reconstruisez jour après
jour que ça va mieux c'est très
compliqué vraiment oui c'est fini
non non non parce que les rares
occasions j'ai été voir un psy mon psy
était voir un psy donc
ah oui c'est incroyable il y en a
un qui a arrêté la psychanalyse l'autre
il ya eu des quelques séances j'ai eu
des nouvelles il ya pas si longtemps que
ça on se doit l'arrivée à s'ouvrir
aujourd'hui quand même à rire aksil oui
oui parce qu'on n'a pas le choix sinon
on meurt 1
il faut il faut sourire vous êtes c'est
pacsés mariés vous n'êtes pas du tout
j'ai quelqu'un dans ma vie d'accord on
voit très bien là que j'embrasse
d'ailleurs ce que je sais qu'ils me
regardent et 7
c'est quelqu'un qui connaissait votre
histoire qui oui oui oui et ce qu'elle
m'a connu dans des conditions très très
très compliqué ma connu à la rue à la
connu mon enfermement psychiatrie et
c'est avec ces terrains donc tout ça je
gens parlent ils ont parlé dans l'eee
pad et jonathan je voudrais vous
remercier d'être venu d'abord été le
témoin ce soir le témoin du jour
jonathan de l'est au delà de
l'irréparable une vie d'enfant de l'
affaire d'outreau vraiment un livre
incroyable et une histoire incroyable
merci et jonathan d'avoir été là ça vous
nous donner des news vraiment merci
moment là et merci et égard d essayer de
garder le sourire ici mais voilà bel
vivre maintenant vraiment en essais pour
vous essayer de vivre là vous êtes vous
savez lire bien vous êtes bien tout va
bien faut essayer de vivre avec ses
blessures mais c est de vivre et de
essayer de profiter de la télé c'est
plus facile à dire qu'à faire
j'espère que vous allez y arriver en
tout cas merci merci merci jonathan
d'avoir été avec nous